[Music]
even the greatest eSports players have
bad days of the office oh this could be
it
yeah mute you can't wait to put it and
score you but no less well take it now
my boy looks like he's gonna cry in the
car okay because this is the largest
bull deficit that's 20 that's the next
great response considering yet no
information no read on where he was was
nice to laugh but was unbelievable
cool aren't you believe the world's top
player just business a massive shot
snacks gets the kill and we're gonna be
on 15 rounds as a result because Tazz
takes fur and fallen that's the round
gone in the hands of coldzera what was
that but in League of Legends there's
one superstar in particular who's become
known for his consistent ability to
reach the highest of highs only to
follow it up with the lowest of lows and
over the course of his career it's
created an inescapable conflict within
him you probably know rasmus caps
Winther as one of two things you think
of him as either one of the best Western
players ever to touch League of Legends
not sure the Jensens gonna be able
actually finish this off and look at
cats going in for one you see everything
to go in stealing be terrifying all
right
I'm so distraught that now gets stolen
we traded caps doesn't even lose 10% of
his HP or he's that player who became a
huge mean because of his legendary
inconsistency caps cannot find the
engaging hip suppose though he's on the
Nexus whoops your Nexus starting to go
long
[Music]
now whichever man you've heard of the
two versions of this acclaimed player
claps and craps have both made plenty of
appearances over the years claps is the
brand name world-class talent while
craps is well the cheap knockoff Hey
but in order for caps to have a shot in
hell at becoming the player he was
destined to be he was gonna have to
learn to live with being both but she's
just super squishy variable that's HAP's
no this is good from the moment he burst
onto the European scene caps has been an
exciting prospect for Western League of
Legends fans he's built a reputation for
having a laid-back happy-go-lucky
attitude and an in-game play style that
doesn't match it at all cause it's going
solo rooted in place by nukes a lot the
heel cups are very very good things to
subjugate but caps get to kill to juggle
the celestial expansion is ticking
damage away that's a triple by caps all
right no flash available caps is gonna
need to find some sort of stun or
ultimate yeah she just gets chunked out
[Applause]
this is all in the making so much
earlier on in the game as Mickey now
going for a bit of a fighting scan oh
man caps even side steps the pop blossom
let's go image chasing the flash forward
perfect execution using caps honestly
makes that look easy
for better or worse caps has a vision
for how to win games and it's pretty
simple kill everything in front of you
and that trademark balls-to-the-wall
aggressive play style paired with insane
mechanical ability led him to being
compared to a certain Korean goats
please sound up to some form of Korean
goat yeah please actually just yeah when
you someone does something cool
something fancy people will say oh
you're Vega and then because of my age I
think people started saying like oh baby
Vega and even before those comparisons
were first being made let's just say
that caps was pretty confident and that
arrogance was put on display when the
young Dayne decided to smack talk that
goats in soloqueue which well didn't
exactly go his way
don't worry caps there's no shame in
being dunked on by faker
it could be worse dude you could be Ryu
what anyway in 2017 caps kicked off his
professional career with fnatic where he
really established himself as a force to
be reckoned with let's see what he can
do
follows up with a few manages to get the
loft breath as well as shield comes up
condition enabled that was insane from
caps impact will knock his smack down
smoothly gets the kill but here comes
the rub topside Broxson
and caps joining in for this one Oh does
not have a way out he can charge for
some damage but he will be killed off a
knight straight for fnatic
but caps wasn't just a murderer on the
rift during his days on fnatic he was
also a killer on the microphone what are
you gonna do to perks in Copenhagen I'm
gonna smash him so hard that he's gonna
finger this nation the international
tournament as it turned out though caps
is boundless confidence proved to be a
double-edged sword it led to some
incredible payoffs in the one verse at
one great stun cat looking for it does
put the manga a dead busboy that's a
solo kill cat does it in style but it
also produced some head scratching
blunders against the biology caps was
clearly an amazing player but this one
speed all-or-nothing approach true
criticism and with it means fans began
to characterize caps as two players
rolled into one he was both claps the
mind-blowing Lane virtuoso and craps the
feeding brainless berserker I think it
comes down to his play style I think
comes onto his mentality he plays to win
regardless if he's ahead neutral or
behind he's going to look for the out
play he is that talented he's going to
look for the 1 B 2 or the 1 V 3 or push
that extra wave because he's playing for
the win and that means sometimes when
you are struggling when you are behind
or you are outmatched it's going to look
worse and that's why I think that the
craps version of his personality looks
as bad as it does
despite nabbing back-to-back domestic
championships in 2018 and earning
himself an MVP trophy along the way caps
wasn't able to shake the claps or craps
reputation he had earned with fnatic and
it really came to a head when fnatic
faced Invictus gaming in the world's
2018 grand finals while the EU roster
was simply outclassed all over the rift
collapse was nowhere to be found we are
see the individual talent show up here
on the big stage they're looking at him
fair
Jaffe's is going to be nearly killed
instantly but get that nearly it's
unstoppable for Jackie love oh he'll a
song it's a slow painful kind of damp
and no Ming swoops in meanwhile Jackie
he's unstoppable underneath the turret
and Cavs cannot get away Gillis song
wants to hang out off to the side see if
maybe he can find something cash grabs a
laser but it's Bell Laden the backline
looking to buy him everybody here comes
your hextech ultimatum in the air gaily
ultimate things gonna be taken low goes
into the stasis Jackie's legendary
they've already found the killing of
snow as they've already found the
killing of cats
it's the solo laners down and IG aren't
pushing for the wind rocks and reckless
versus the world
reckless goes on a rampage but Ning is
still there pressuring onto the turret
with the rest of IG reckless is down
Bronx's away I cheer on the Nexus the
LPL has never won before but that will
change today the crownless are finally
King and Invictus gaming on your 2018
world champions after the disappointment
of losing grand finals caps decided that
it was time for a change
so naturally he decided to join fanatics
greatest rival g2 while the move didn't
exactly sit well with fnatic it actually
made a lot of sense for gaps thousand
for love's teams
I thought you two looked the most
interesting I feel like that place I was
very like its they play the same kind of
way that I wanna play they have a like a
very aggressive mindset and they are
okay with making mistakes as long as
they're like proactive she to gave caps
more than just a chance to play on a
super team after joining he quickly
discovered that his new teammates
offered him a kind of support that went
beyond the rift I'm really happy with
how things are because I feel like it's
much more like a team we're doing a lot
more things together
seriously it's adorable these guys get
haircuts together eat shawarma together
and kick ass in league together with g2
caps was joining an organization known
for not taking itself too seriously and
that was the perfect fit for his
personality
that's right but the real game-changer
was that g2 was willing to let caps play
league his way this meanie Band of
Brothers was seriously committed to a
high-risk high-reward play style that
caps loved if he went all-in they were
right behind him
Oh G just had no response looks like
caps as a kid III don't mean a
derogatory I don't mean a defensive
he's young at heart he's innocent he
wants to play the game with people who
want to play have fun be silly in my
opinion for caps to excel and to enjoy
what he's doing and to retain the
essence of caps I think he needs that
truly silly supportive sometimes
offensive g2 and players around him and
even though craps did occasionally make
cameo appearances in G choose games the
bromance boosted claps rarely gave up
the spotlight
sync up so in the middle of fight he's
gonna try to buy the XUV is gonna get
one back but have to stop - I'm cutting
through the rest of his team that
receptor there for the jumps one he's
looking for the next one on the kick as
a daisy
and just all too good for cap but
signatures firing back the irelia the
ribbon they don't need to fight each
other they're just gonna kill each
other's team syntax though now on the
backfoot has to - once look for the cube
- one two and three but the ignite the
power just finish don't even look at him
die
just take it in stride caps now going to
run for his life want to take a grab a
grasp lit by the more time but don't
want to turn it in step I thought he was
not having it caps turns to play around
into this that this is the dominance
we've come to know from G to go down in
your mind that they are the top team in
the alley see but caps and g2 weren't
gonna be satisfied with just domestic
dominance they carried their momentum
all the way through MSI 2019 toppling
faker and SKT on the way to [ __ ]
stomping team liquid in the grand finals
ng to blow back that's a big
look at the fight they look for killed
number four this might be an ace inside
of the base inside of eighteen minutes
the main hitter will surely fall and g2
ripped through the hearts of Team Liquid
a North American fans as they secure
themselves in the top of the world there
is no chance TL comes back from this
never already our Nexus turret this is
what peak League of Legends looks like
and it comes from Europe a world record
g2 eSports 3-0 win twenty nineteen g2
eSports
dear Emma side 2019 champions Europe is
now top dog in league of legends
although it seemed like caps had wiped
away the remnants of craps the potential
for his unflushable alter-ego to
re-emerge had become entrenched in the
community so much so that right even
animated his internal struggle in their
music video for the world's 2019 song at
that event g2 ran into faker and SKT yet
again making fans wonder which version
of caps they were going to get had he
finally removed the stain that was craps
once and for all give me your final
words for SKT next week I think you
faker should be scared cuz fluffs is
coming and perks wasn't wrong
claps showed up and went toe-to-toe with
the unkillable demon king in one of the
best series of the year back into that
take it down by the greatest team
europeís burp reduce the apps
get ready g2 is heading to Paris
even though caps was riding high after
triumphing over faker the Grand Finals
against fun plus Phoenix were a
different story
while craps might not have turtle headed
his way into the series that didn't stop
it from being a total [ __ ] show thus not
letting them get to play on the map here
we go they're all headed very cheeky
he's already
dude he doesn't have the charge
available two three fighting the triple
G to our East at 22 minutes right back
out apparently is the target it will be
secured the tussle it's a consequence
one hero's entrance comes in to impede
he's chasing forward
maanteeeca this could be it now wanders
in troubles caps wisconsin under the he
needs to do so much more will be
vectorized doesn't
members of Phoenix but in spite of the
dumpster in the jutsu received fpx never
broke their spirits even as they were
being dominated g2 never stopped
laughing and having fun because I kind
of good until it wasn't but yeah I think
it maybe we shove them and I sorted out
them yeah say the same right with the
rustle me oh yeah they appeared a week
when they were actually at the end of
the day cap still has plenty of time to
achieve his world championship dreams
but what makes him truly outstanding is
his refusal to compromise when it comes
to how he wants to play the game see
without that full throttle aggression
neither claps nor craps can exist and
for caps staying true to those dueling
identities and enjoying the game with
his friends might just be more important
than any trophy he could lift I actually
think the only good thing about League
of Legends the only good thing is
actually the expec everything else about
League of Legends is just a colossal
[ __ ] unflushable turd the crap
stained once and for all
you're giving away too much [ __ ]
satisfaction out of this my house just
loves a good pujo guys let's just do a
lot of a lot of goats yeah
that's more of a sheep though isn't it
ah what's the difference raincoat
[Music]